the remains of an one GUI karanji are
carried by her friends into the church
they all used to attend in Nakuru the
teacher was flying home from Canada with
her daughter and three grandchildren
when they Theo pian airlines jet crashed
in March
killing all a hundred and fifty seven
people on board most of the bodies were
burned beyond recognition and it has
taken months of DNA analysis to identify
the remains we must heal first before
anything else even when it comes to
compensation let seek God's guidance and
everything will work out 32 Kenyans were
on board the Boeing 737 max which
crashed soon after takeoff from addis
ababa boeing admitted a faulty sensor
contributed to the disaster the entire
737 max fleet has been grounded since
the accident
which followed another in Indonesia a
year ago
boeing is paying compensation to the
families of all the victims the pain in
this neighborhood is felt by everyone
one goal was a community leader
neighbors watched her daughter Caroline
grow up and don't head on her
grandchildren when they were home on
holiday an on boy's family says for now
they're just glad we can finally bury
their loved ones initially I thought the
impact was so good but not amenable
forgotten but luckily enough when we
went what they had to open the boxes and
the identify part of your eye
they here so what else you doing it you
just feel he/she is the right person
whom you have been playing that one day
before she'll be remembered for many
things Sam says she brought out the best
in children she thought she was also a
loving mother and grandmother to those
who died with her
catherine soy al jazeera Ikuo Kenya